hey I'm Shalom check out this exclusive
Blue Beetle clip on Voodoo
[Music]
doing the Reyes home was very fun as a
wonderful expression I think of what it
is to grow up in a Latino home
the Reyes house is really like the heart
of the film there's so many little
things in there that are so authentic
I was able to go back and think about
growing up oftentimes in Hispanic
culture you need places to put things
but you don't have a curious set or a
cabinet or something so oftentimes
they'll just start cutting into the
walls and then they'll use the two by
fours to help frame the walls to put
some shelves in and then voila you've
got a shelf unit and visiting my
grandparents and my abuelas they had the
Vietnam Guadalupe that's not just a
picture it's like a shrine
so I was able to bring a lot of these
things in that surrounded me in my youth
Blue Beetle it's a movie that centers
around a Mexican American character in
an unabashedly Latin American movie
that's what makes it different it's
every detail it's in every fiber and
every shot in every character in every
costume and in the people making it I
never been in a movie who talk about
Latin people as this movie I have put
the values of Latin and Mexican people
not only that for a good people for the
minority we're often shown as gangsters
or narcos it's never so much about our
values and What Makes Us special it's
such an important thing to see yourself
represented on screen behind the camera
as well you know someone who looks like
you someone whose family kind of is like
your family sounds like your family eats
the same food as your family seeing that
portrayed in a positive light is so
immense and so powerful to see people
like me with hopes and dreams with a
loving family that cares I'm eventually
becoming superheroes of Our Own Story
it's it's very special nobody can tell
our stories better than ourselves
I mean just the idea to begin with and I
have to speak as a as a Latina
Historia Revolution
you know is it always the right time no
was there a better time maybe but the
times now so the Blue Beetle is um
it's pretty amazing